es sind erschreckende Bilder die vor dem
chinesischen Konsulat in Manchester
aufgenommen werden
Videos die über die sozialen Kanäle
verbreitet werden zeigen wie offenbar
chinesische Angestellte des Konsulats
Protestplakate auf der Straße mutwillig
zerstören
demonstriert wird hier gegen den
chinesischen Präsidenten skising-ping
der sich aktuell in China von der
Kommunistischen Partei für eine weitere
Amtszeit bestätigen lässt
ein Demonstrant wird bei dem Gerangel
von der Straße auf das Gelände des
chinesischen Konsulats gezogen und
verprügelt
britische Polizisten zögern erst
schreiten dann jedoch ein und helfen dem
Mann
die Polizei von Manchester leitet jetzt
eine Untersuchung ein britische
Politiker bezeichnen den Vorfall als
äußerst besorgniserregend wie es dem
verprügelten Mann geht ist aktuell
unklar